I don't know why recently I just started
I switched over I had this bad habit of
I I drink a lot of diet soda oh and uh
people have been telling me that's not
good for you so I switched over to uh
Iced Green Tea
and I think I'm gonna live an extra day
and that's it I am of that mind because
my wife is very much she's so naturally
healthy yeah uh and I'm quite fatalistic
about it that might be an sort of an
Irish quality but I just think ah you go
and you go and so all this I think I
could eat
all kinds of healthy stuff and drink all
kinds of healthy stuff which I do but I
don't think it's going to change things
it's a tough call right because you want
to prolong your life but you also want
to enjoy your life so where do you draw
the line well I would like to be a
burden on my children okay I want to do
that thing where I become very old very
quickly and then I have to uh I'm just a
huge pain in the ass okay I feel like
after a while people will just leave you
in your wheelchair just like in the
corner I'm sorry I was just checking you
that's what that's a lot of caffeine is
it isn't it well green tea has less
caffeine than coffee I know but the
amount he's drinking I do but you know
what I caffeine does not affect me are
you sure yes this is a uh fact and you
can check this where would I check this
back I know how would we know if my wife
you could ask my wife I will drink
coffee at night and then go to sleep I
can have I've had uh massive doses of
coffee and then gone right to sleep and
they say that it's a gene that it's uh I
also they say it's a red-haired thing
but uh I need tons of anesthetic to put
me down really yeah
no they have to hit me with like seven
Rhino darts when I go to the dentist if
they just want to put a you know drill a
new cavity because they're always saying
okay that's enough and then they start
to put the drill and I go
and they say really more and I go huh
and then they come in and some I've had
I've seen as many as like seven people
come in with different syringes are
caffeinated they're all I know they're
all jabbing at my head and then finally
they get this uh this crazy Cobra to
settle down and they work on my my
Chompies which is what I call my teeth
really crazy Cobra yeah
and the Chompies that's my band I'm
crazy it's crazy Cobra in the Chompies
tonight at the Odeon theater is it true
the redheaded thing and I've heard that
really uh yes unreliable no I've heard
it from uh doctors I actually heard it
from an esthetician that there is a they
think that there's a link to the uh
red-haired Gene and
um a tolerance
for uh all kinds of
um anesthetics was this anesthetologist
redheaded yeah no is being red-headed
I'm not saying this be me is it an
abnormality like is there something
about your genetic structure that is are
you a freak weird and not proper well uh
I wouldn't recommend it
how about that because it usually means
you have very fair skin which I do yeah
which means I'm really
um especially these days uh with the
amount of uh light coming from the Sun
that permeates our damaged atmosphere
yeah I'm doomed I'm doomed and uh we are
but but it's a very it's a very strange
Gene like my brothers and sisters are
not we're not redheads and when I look
at these pictures of me as a little kid
and I my hair was even brighter it was
like a carrot red it's like a glitch
it's like having webbed feet
well I do have webbed feet
you know that right I
you know that when I said it
Eduardo I'll do it under the table
because I think it's a little disgusting
I didn't I remember you saying this when
I said it I didn't know that you did but
oh
oh this is like when I showed my back oh
God look at that yes uh my is it my
third and fourth toe there's webbing
in between it
um does she like I don't know is she
drinking well she was drinking plutonium
in the uh second and third trimester
you're like the Water World guy you got
you like a mariner you can swim faster
yeah yeah maybe I'm more highly evolved
because I have webbing on one of my feet
between the third and fourth toe you
know what's a drag for me swimming no
the sun I'm quite a good swimmer no
what's a drag for me is by if if I want
it and I don't but I was in a uh like an
REI once and I love REI and I say that
all the time it's like my happy place I
love to look at all the different gear
and uh I went over to the like boot
section to check everything out and they
had those kind of cool things that you
put on your feet and it's like a a
rubbery uh a rubbery
uh glove that goes on your feet that uh
allows your foot to move more naturally
and they're designed in such a way so
that each toe slides in this is cool
shoes the toe shoes yeah you touched a
bullet yeah hold on this person was
telling me all the advantages of them
this is a very sad moment in my life
this woman was saying oh they're really
it's great for this and great for that
and I said well you know I I'll I'll try
one on so she went and she started to
slide it on my foot and because of my
webbing it stopped and she kept pushing
and she said what's wrong I can't get
this on and I was like ah and then she
took it off and she went yeah
[Laughter]
man yeah I mean it was just uh my
webbing yeah no I know that I don't
really think those are cool but you know
when you can't have something you only
want it more yeah so the other day I'm
walking along and I see this guy
strolling in those same feet gloves and
he's strolling along and I'm enraged and
I can't have that oh yeah you dodged a
bullet those shoes would give me toe
claustrophobia I couldn't put those on
toe claustrophobia sure okay yeah here's
what I'm gonna say I have heard those
shoes are better but I also think you're
abnormalities stop which are stop saying
like your friends you probably aren't
I'm saying there are normal people and
then there's abnormal people with
abnormal qualities what's sad about
freckles what's sad about freckles
you're not trying you're not trying at
all you're just I'm being scientific
about this it's not normal to be a
redhead I'm I'm I'm like two minutes
from being chased into a tower yeah
that's then set a fire Yeah by an angry
mid-century mob yeah hi uh you know
what's sad about freckles is that it's
the it's a terrible idea but it's
Evolution was was thinking uh we gotta
help this guy out a little bit let's
give him a little bit of skin tone in
tiny splotches here and there all over
his body
and I'm just keep thinking about
wherever the assembly line is wherever
Dimension the assembly line is they're
like oh he has no melanin he's just the
whitest thing we've ever seen give him
some protection what do you mean and
splatter him with a little bit
okay okay we did it doesn't look right
hey change his hair to a carry orange
how's that does that help not really
I've got it grab his left foot and
create a duck like webbing between his
third and fourth toe should we do both
feet no no okay okay what are you stupid
sorry sorry just the left
good I think he's ready to go hey I know
one last thing load him up with
self-hate
and pull the lever
there he goes where did he land in that
family where everyone's yelling uh
hey my grandpa was a red-headed fellow
and I have very fun and how was he
murdered by himself
no I have very fond memories of him and
I think you're a fine looking
distinguished thank you thank you I uh I
appreciate that yeah well listen I'm the
now well you know what you did
I'm saying scientifically these things
are not given to everybody else you're
you're saying she's calling the assembly
line they're like oh fix it I I'm
thinking the assembly line they were
like let's this one up
let's this one up who on the
assembly line ever says that what
Keebler Elf ever what what
technician at Ford or Chrysler or BMW
ever said let's this one up let's
make him really tall and skinny too
let's give him really long feet and they
come super tall there's a reason a lot
of people aren't redheads I'm just
saying what's the reason because it's
not normal
well sorry no no no I'm good I love you
you know I love you I know that you I
know you love me yes the way Cher loved
the boy in Mass
um
uh Rocky Dennis yeah sure sure I'll
throw in a Rocky Dennis reference
anytime thanks a lot Sona I love you too
and I'm gonna go out and fit myself for
a bag that goes in my head uh all right
let's get into it